[Music]
it's time for et's social study a quick
look at what the stars are posting
online who are you voting for
I don't know grace maybe I'll stay home
on December first get ready for more
Will & Grace the cast shared
behind-the-scenes peeks on social media
reuniting over the weekend while filming
their 10 episode limited revival we all
come together but it's all out of
unconditional love man and everybody's
in grace period moving on Nick Cannon
shares an adorable family photo of his
twins Moroccan and Monroe spending
quality time with his newborn son with
expert evil
here's a priceless photo of big sis Roe
holding her baby brother golden then
there's Iman sharing a rare photo of her
and late husband David Boies 16 year old
daughter Lexi who inherited her father's
good looks meanwhile sailor Brinkley has
a message for her online body shamers
Christie Brinkley's daughter posted this
pic from her Sports Illustrated shoot
and photoshopped kimochi style butts
around the pig quote apparently
Instagram isn't the biggest fan of my
little bum and I have been deleted and
reported to that I say let them see Kate
and Britney Spears struts her stuff in
another Instagram runway show
they don't love you like I love you step
down they don't know
back up they don't have you step down
they don't know